>> Tucker: IN FACT, SHE'S BEEN
ENDORSED BY ALEX
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT SHE
BELIEVES STRONGLY IN DEFUNDING
THE POLICE.
IN A RECENT DEBATE, SHE
SUGGESTED WE MIGHT DISARM THE
NEW YORK CITY POLICE DEPARTMENT.
>> ATTORNEY GENERAL TISH JAMES
IS PROPOSING LEGISLATION TO
LIMIT COPS FROM FIRING THEIR
WEAPONS, USE OF FORCE AS A LAST
RESORT.
SOME MIGHT ASK, WHY NOT GO ALL
THE WAY AND TAKE AWAY THE GUNS
ALTOGETHER?
>> LOOK, ONE OF THE THINGS WE
HAVE TO DO IS ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THE MAYOR'S JOB IS SAFETY.
AND THAT DOES MEAN THAT WE WANT
A SMART POLICING I THINK WE
KNOW -- >> DO YOU TAKE THE GUNS
AWAY FROM THE NYPD?
>> I'M NOT PREPARED TO MAKE A
DECISION IN A DEBATE.
>> Tucker: YOU'D BE SURPRISED
BY TWO THINGS.
ONE, SHE'S BEEN FUNDED BY GEORGE
SOROS.
THE SECOND THING YOU MIGHT NOT
BE SHOCKED TO LEARN, WE LEARN
THIS FROM THE DAILY MAIL, IS
THAT SHE DOESN'T BELIEVE IN
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
HOW DO WE KNOW THIS?
BECAUSE HER AND HER NEIGHBORS
PAY THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR THEIR OWN PRIVATE POLICE TO
PROTECT THEIR OWN NEIGHBORHOOD.
A COLUMNIST AT THE NEAR POST
JOINS US TONIGHT TO ASSESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
IT'S KIND OF AMAZING THAT
SOMEONE WITH A STRAIGHT FACE
WOULD SAY, DEFUND THE POLICE,
TAKE AWAY THEIR GUNS, THAN PAY
FOR YOUR OWN PRIVATE POLICE.
OR SHOULD WE NOT BE SHOCKED?
>> I WAS ON YOUR SHOW AND I SAID
THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
DEFUND THE POLICE ARE RICH
PEOPLE.
AND HERE WE GO, MAIA WILEY TO
PROVE IT.
A RICH PERSON WANTS TO STRIP FOR
PEOPLE OF SERVICES.
THEY WANT TO TAKE AWAY THEIR
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
WANTS TO TAKE EDUCATION AWAY
FROM OTHER PEOPLE'S KIDS.
EVEN THOUGH HER KIDS GO TO
PRIVATE SCHOOL.
SO SHE'S ONE OF THE TYPICAL
HYPOCRITES THAT WE HAVE RUNNING
IN NEW YORK CITY, BUT MAIA WILEY
CANDIDACY IS FOR PEOPLE WHO LIKE
BEING INCOMPETENCE OF THE BILL
de BLASIO ADMINISTRATION.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S SO
INTERESTING, AND HONESTLY IN
FEAR RATING, IS THAT MAIA WILEY
IS A RICH PERSON, IT'S OKAY, I
AM TOO, SHE SENDS HER KIDS TO
PRIVATE SCHOOL, SHE HAS PRIVATE
SECURITY, BUT SHE POSES AS A
VICTIM.
HOW DOES SHE GET AWAY WITH THAT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WELL, A FRIENDLY MEDIA ALWAYS
HELPS.
I THINK NEW YORK LIBERALS ARE
JUST LIKE HER.
THEY ARE ALSO WEALTHY AND ALSO
WANT TO DEFUND THE POLICE AND
HAVE IN THEIR MINDS THEY CAN
ALWAYS HIRE PRIVATE SECURITY.
I SAW IT MAYOR BILL de BLASIO
WALKING ON THE PART OF MIDDLE OF
THE DAY, AND HE DIDN'T HAVE
SECURITY WITH HIM.
SHE REALLY IS DOING THINGS, NOT
AS THEY DO.
>> Tucker: THERE SHOULD BE
SOME KIND OF LAW THAT REQUIRES
THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE OUR LAWS TO
LIVE WITH THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THE LAWS THEY MAKE.
>> THAT WOULD BE NICE, TUCKER.
I'M NOT GOING TO COUNT ON MAIA
WILEY TO PASS ANY LAWS LIKE
THAT, BECAUSE I THINK THEY
WOULD BE MOST HARMFUL TO HER.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE INTO
EQUITY, DIVERSITY, INCLUSION,
YOU SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO GO
TO ASPEN OR MARTHA'S VINEYARD
EVER.
YOU SHOU